klärung für supermassereiche schwarze
löcher gefunden
sie sind eines der großen rätsel im
universum supermassereiche schwarze
löcher jetzt ein klick zum science
fiction supermassereiche schwarze löcher
sie sind riesig sie können 1 milliarden
faches der masse der sonne haben und
befinden sich meistens in den zentren
von galaxien in der mitte unserer
galaxie der milchstraße befindet sich
ein solches schwarzes loch geschätzt
wird es auf 4,3 millionen sonnenmassen
aber woher es kommt ob es überhaupt erst
die existenz unserer galaxie ermöglicht
hat das sind fragen die noch nicht
geklärt werden konnten mit den
weltraumteleskopen chandra hubble und
spitzer haben forscher des nationalen
instituts für astrophysik in italien
jetzt aber zwei supermassereiche
schwarze löcher gefunden die auf einem
anderen weg als alle anderen schwarzen
löcher vermutlich entstanden sein sollen
im prinzip können schwarze löcher
entstehen wenn ein stern stürmt nach
einem gravitations kollaps wird aus
einem schweren stern ein schwarzes loch
dieser stern muss dann auch wirklich
sehr schwer sein es sind wohl so rund 15
bis 25 sonnenmassen notwendig damit ein
schwarzes loch überhaupt gebildet werden
kann wenn bei einem stern dieser größe
die fusion zum erliegen kommt weil der
brennstoff verbrannt ist dann fehlt der
strahlungsdruck als gegenkraft zur
gravitation die kräfte in den atomkern
reichen nicht mehr als gegenkraft aus
und der stern stürzt in sich zusammen
der besagte kollaps unsere sonne wird
niemals zum schwarzen loch werden dafür
hat sie zu wenig masse schwarze löcher
entstehen deswegen aus sternen weil dort
der druck im inneren groß genug ist um
eine kernfusion zu starten
das unterscheidet auch sterne vom
planeten denn es gibt zwar planeten die
ebenfalls aus glas bestehen in deren
inneren läuft allerdings keine
fusionsreaktion ab planeten wachsen des
weiteren auch nicht einfach so
schwarze löcher können durchaus immer
größer werden die gravitation vom
planeten ist eben zu gering ein
schwarzes loch wächst indem es materie
in seiner nähe anzieht und in sich
aufnimmt es verschluckt sie regelrecht
der strudel der durch das ansaugen der
materie entsteht bildet eine
genannte akkretionsscheibe die hell
aufleuchtet bevor sie verschluckt wird
die starke strahlung die dabei entsteht
bremst die nachfolgende materie
allerdings aus dadurch gibt es eine
natürliche grenze für ein schwarzes loch
direkt kann man die grenze und die
schwarzen löcher selbst übrigens gar
nicht sehen denn ein schwarzes loch
reflektiert kann ich sagt ja alles auf
aber wir können die auswirkungen eines
schwarzen loches sehen
denn wenn beispielsweise viel gas auf
ein schwarzes loch zu kommt wird es
beschleunigt und eis diese heiße
strahlung können wir dann in form von
röntgenstrahlung mit technischen
hilfsmitteln wahrnehmen durch die hohen
masse der schwarzen löcher
kommt es zu einem einfluss auf das
zeitraum conti nun die gravitation
krümmt den raum extrem er dreht sich in
die richtung der rotation des schwarzen
lochs bei den zwei jetzt entdeckten
schwarzen löchern aber hätte sich der
vorgang ganz anders abgespielt zitat
unsere entdeckung könnte wenn sie sich
bestätigt erklären wie die monster unter
den schwarzen löchern geboren wurden
denn wir haben mit ihnen belege dafür
gefunden dass die vorläufer
supermassereiche schwarze löcher direkt
aus dem kollaps einer gewaltigen
gaswolke entstehen können ohne weitere
zwischenschritte so der astronom fabio
paratici damit werden zum ersten mal
schwarze löcher entdeckt worden die
nicht aus sternen entstanden wären die
entstehung von galaxien könnte also
vollkommen anders erklärt werden bei der
spektralanalyse der schwarzen löcher
viel den forschern auf das für schwere
materie charakteristische linien fehlen
würden die schwarzen löcher aus toten
sternen resultieren hätte man solche
linien nachweisen können
beide hätten eine masse von rund 100.000
sonnen und wären ungefähr eine milliarde
jahre nach dem urknall entstanden ganz
sicher sei man sich aber nicht zitat als
wissenschaftler können wir nicht sagen
dass unser modell das einzig wahre ist
aber wir glauben dass unser modell die
beobachtung reproduzieren kann ohne
dafür auf unwahrscheinlicher annahmen
zurückgreifen zu müssen erklärt paci
welche theorien zu schwarzen löchern
kennt ihr und welche haltet ihr für
richtig lass es mich mal in den
kommentaren wissen und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann lasse gerne
einen daumen nach
oben und ein kostenloses abo da und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran